joining me back here on the Rich Eisen
show from the Pittsburgh Steelers who
once upon a time one in four now form
for a big game against the Los Angeles
Rams and one of the many reasons why
this defense has vastly improved this
year's because they went in and reached
out and got a Michigan man his name is
Devon Bush back here in the program how
you doing Devon good how are you I'm
doing fine how have you found your first
professional season
midway through so far good good it's fun
I learned a lot here on a bunch of guys
I love football based I mean if the
journey comes to what have you learned a
lot I just learned how to be a
professional mainly I think that's the
biggest thing I learned how to have
balance you know with your life on the
field and off the field so I'm still you
know in the works of digging that out
and you know and going through my first
year a way through and I think I'm on
the right track we sort of that what do
you mean you needed some you're trying
to grab balance what do you mean by that
yeah you're professional on it off the
field you know and everything is not
gonna be perfect on the field of course
you know we started the season you know
what a couple losses and you know
Connors people were starting to think
you know we lost our starting
quarterback in a kind of just off the
field you know I didn't bought my first
house you know that's cool you know
getting getting those things done get
everything situated and being able to
work off the field you know doing the
Paris there's a whole bunch of things
and so just carry myself as professional
getting things done you know at work and
after work powers Tomlin put his
thumbprint on this team walk me through
that to Devon I think the biggest thing
coach Tomlin doesn't seem
straightforward um he's never trying to
trick you to anything he's never trying
to lead you the wrong way you know he
tells you black and white you know your
circumstances you know on the team as
well as your role and what he's looking
and expecting at you even so he's not
you walk it's not like you're walking
into Briony you know it's kind of got an
expectation so you got to live up to
that and only you've got control over
that
sure share with me what he told you is
his expectations of you he came out in
like Express that you know but um I know
I know coach Tomlin believes in me I
know the team does and I know it's
coaches tab does so you know I'm gonna
do my best to be the best player I could
be so you're one of two rookies with
multiple interceptions this season and
only one of two rookies with a defensive
touchdown this season what has been the
biggest adjustment from the collegiate
Big Ten level to the National Football
League for you out there on the field
Devan everybody everybody everybody
strong everybody's elite so I think
that's that's one thing you got to get
adjusted to it's like it's not all about
how physically gifted you are it's about
how mentally sharp you are how huh you
know ready and how you prepare and
what's the challenge that the Rams
present to you that you've already seen
on film or discussed in your meeting
rooms Devon yeah they got weapons
everywhere um offense defense and
special teams and you know they play as
a good team collectively they feed off
each other they play in the Super Bowl
so they have the formula you know
they've been there they've been in big
games you know so these guys are trying
to fire on all cylinders and you know
they just present a lot of a lot of good
matchups
you know stability a lot of good matches
Sunday of course with all girly the
Titans they have no golf and now the
defense is really good of course and
Donald J Lee Ramsey the bunch of guys
that I played a major role in that in
that rams you know team and they do a
good job
Devin Busch here in the Rich Eisen show
you know in the NFL 100 season will go
way back to before you were born between
the Steelers and the Rams in a Super
Bowl that took place between them way
back in the day but I imagine in your
own household growing up there were a
lot of Rams material around because your
dad won a Super Bowl with st. Louis so
that's got to be a little weird in a way
I guess that that the Rams are going to
stand in front of you that way I mean
Michigan play Florida State my freshman
year so I think I've been do it like
that
well you just walked me into this next
one kind of an interesting memory lane
with Michigan playing Michigan State
this weekend don't you think I'm super
excited
okay well let's let's say you and I if
you will lock arms and march down memory
lane on that front Devon what do you
recall about that day do you think uh
the last time the only thing I remember
from that day is 93 total yards office
hmm
that's that speaks for everything so
that's not the only excuse me you're a
professional now you're a man who's
being paid for your work this thing's
called it yeah this thing's called the
past this is not you in any way shape or
form affecting your draft grade or any
no no no sir you are now officially
based on the first eight games this
season a professional grown-ass man
Devon so let's discuss part of the work
that you gave to the grounds crew that
day in East Lansing I had a lot of a lot
of green and white when I bottom of my
cleats that day a lot of that on the
bottom of my cleats they've got this guy
really tippy at them and somebody's logo
got messed up I don't know who did it
yep it was almost a brawl I didn't I
didn't know what was going on but I know
the game all right yep game starts and
then you got all and then then you said
93 total yards of offense yeah but I do
want it I do really want to stir
something up and I honestly and and it's
not purposefully but I want to know
because as a Michigan guy as you know a
Michigan fan and this is this is this is
this is this is a blood rivalry okay and
sometimes literally so with families and
everything dant Dantonio he knew right
he was he was there smiling right he was
smiling good good right he was of course
because you could see he found it he
thought it was funny or he was laughing
as the as the player's arm an arm walk
March
straight through your warmup right yep
all right no well I mean he got you got
he was looking for there was no bad it
was so bad though you know you see the
judge they start wearing what do you
mean you didn't see that Newser no not
yet I would pretty much okay you did
they got these neon juries with state
across the front of them you know think
that's the I don't whoever made that
design I think they did that in the dark
and just last thing on this is it true
they told you that they'd already done
their arms walk through and that you
could go out there and warm up didn't
they tell you that before the game they
told you what when that they did their
their usual drill of walking arm-in-arm
I never I never seen them do that my
whole career yeah not what time did I
did because they said they do it all the
time they say they do whatever you never
never never heard or seen of never to
that day were you gonna watch it
Saturday or do you have a do you have
time to do it what do you got
I'm alive I really want it I really went
ahead over there mm-hmm
okay but I got I got some other things
to do wrong I guess next weekend so but
at some point you'll be watching this
game correct oh yeah feet up so you do
you tweet during the games huh you do
that sometimes it's tough game I am well
it's tough for me man it's tough because
I just get me so pissed off from time to
time but right it's a big game man it's
a big game as you can stay you already
hate Devon look I love strolling down
this memory lane with you brother and
congrats on the way things have started
for you in Pittsburgh it's been fun to
watch and fun to see and let's stay in
touch okay you take care of yourself
Devon that's Devon Bush for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download
Rich Eisen show up